SCP-096 VS SCP-3521. We know looking at the
Shy Guy’s face is enough to drive him bananas,
but can a chaotic deluge of bananas
from within finally kill the monster?
SCP-096 has proven to be almost unstoppable.
Thanks to its indestructible skeleton,
the creature has been almost completely
destroyed in the past and still been
able to pull itself back from the
brink with heightened regeneration.
SCP-3521 is a pill that causes truly
deranged quantities of bananas to appear
inside the victims’ stomach, killing them with
either ionizing radiation from the potassium or
massive bodily trauma from all the bananas.
Though personally, we think 096 could still
survive. Even if its stomach and torso burst open,
spewing bananas everywhere, it would still likely
regenerate once the banana onslaught was done.